two hours after midnight the scientists
begin their day starting with full
containment care even though they're in
a totally different environment than
they're used to a hot muggy buggy night
in a jungle tent not a high level
containment facility in Montana the
dangers are the same these researchers
are catching bats in the Republic of
Congo to answer the question where do a
bola outbreaks come from in 2013
Ebola surfaced in Guinea and spread
quickly to engulf neighboring countries
Liberia and Sierra Leone more than
11,000 people died in the biggest
outbreak on record much is known about
Ebola scientists have characterized the
virus's proteins and sequenced his
genome they've collected blood samples
and clinical data from hundreds of
patients we know some things about its
path to people too but two important
questions remain why does the virus
emerge from the wild suddenly and where
does it lurk when it's not sickening and
killing people a huge hundred and sixty
square meter net is home between trees
to catch the largest bats in Africa
hammer-headed fruit bats which can have
a wingspan of up to one meter a
veterinarian carefully removes the bat
from the net and puts it in a grey bag
one of the other men carries the bat a
few hundred metres to the bush to the
camp and ties it to a rope each bat is
weighed photograph and measured then the
sampling begins the bats are swapped
urine collected and blood is drawn from
a vein in the wing most Ebola outbreaks
have happened here in Central Africa the
first and most deadly type of Ebola was
discovered after the outbreak in 1976
close to the Ebola River more than half
of all outbreaks with this virus have
happened in DRC or Congo Brazzaville
that's why this region seems a good
place to search for the reservoir
scientists have found evidence of Ebola
infection in several bat species but
they have never isolated live virus from
them for release the bats are hung in a
line this time without the bag and when
they recover themselves fly into the
night
the team consists of a virologist from
the rocky mountain lab in Montana and an
epidemiologist and veterinarian from the
Wildlife Conservation Society
the latter studied the impact of Ebola
on chimps and gorillas Ebola is the
biggest threat to gorillas apart from
poaching humans in turn often contract
the virus by handling dead animals or
eating bush meat that's why the program
also involves telling local communities
not to touch dead animals in the forest
but instead call the Wildlife
Conservation Society the samples will be
shipped back to the lab in Montana for
analysis alongside those from earlier
trips it could take months for them to
arrive in the US the hope though is that
the researchers will not only find live
Ebola virus and finally prove that this
bat species is a reservoir for this type
but also that the data over time will
allow them to find patterns that help
explain when and how Ebola is most
likely to spillover from bats to other
animals and ultimately humans that can
help researchers to stop Ebola at its
source
you